Jessica Alba is far from finished as an actress,
but we can't help noticing that we just aren't
seeing as much of her as we used to.
While she seems to appear in a couple of movies
each year, her career has descended from the
high-profile heights of her superhero and
Dark Angel days.
For a little while, in the wake of the first
couple Fantastic Four movies, it seemed like
she might've been done with showbiz for good.
What was so bad behind the scenes that Alba
almost … disappeared?
The scripts sucked
Alba has suffered through more than her share
of serious critical busts, but the Fantastic
Four movies seemed to be the last straw.
Venting about all the bad scripts she'd accepted
over the years, Alba told Elle:
"Good actors never use the script unless it's
amazing writing.
All the good actors I've worked with, they
all say whatever they want to say."
The reaction to those comments was swift.
Screenwriter John August took her to task
for her perceived rudeness, writing:
"Following your logic, you’ve never been
in a movie with both good actors and amazing
writing.
That may be true, but it might hurt the feelings
of David Wain, Robert Rodriguez and Frank
Miller."
Still, it's telling that August failed to
mention Tim Story, director of the Fantastic
Four, either.
Maybe even he recognized that maybe Alba might've
been justified in hating that one.
And speaking of Tim Story...
They made her feel worthless
There can't be anything more demoralizing
for an actor than being asked not to do their
job.
But that's exactly the sort of treatment Alba
says she received during the filming of the
widely panned Fantastic Four sequel.
During one scene in Rise of the Silver Surfer,
Alba was supposed to be emotional.
Director Tim Story reportedly berated her,
saying, "It looks too real, it looks too painful."
According to Alba:
"He was like, 'Don't do that thing with your
face.
Just make it flat.
We can CG the tears in.'
And so I just said, 'F— it.
I don't care about this business anymore.'"
The movies were ripped apart by critics
"An overinflated B-movie with no grace, no
subtext, no wit, and featuring beefcake/cheesecake
actors."
"Terribly miscast."
"The movie should almost be ashamed to show
itself."
There's no two ways about it.
Far from fantastic, these movies were horribly
received, especially compared to genre contemporaries
like Spider-Man 2, Batman Begins, and X-Men.
The reviews were particularly unkind to the
actors.
Their performances were called thin, their
characters two-bit, and critics generally
wrote off their hard work as a waste of time.
That hurricane of hate would be enough to
make anybody doubt their career choices.
For her part, Alba has shown a lot of self-awareness
when it comes to the quality of some of her
pictures, telling Elle:
"I know I haven't been swimming in the deep
end with some of the movies I've done.
I wasn't trying to.
I knew what they were.
I'd been so afraid of criticism ever since
I was young.
Every time I'd get a critique or some redirection,
I'd always just take it very personally."
Is that any surprise she'd want to walk away?
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw...